my concern is i've got someone
like you multi-disciplinary polymath
james lindsey phd in pure mathematics
i don't want the brightest minds of our
time to
be taken up i don't want this in the
nicest way possible i wish that you
hadn't had to write this book
yes um why are you bored
of talking about social justice you know
fantastic question more than bored i'm
indignant
so it's oftentimes the most one of the
most indignant people i know yeah i love
it and
but and sometimes people say oh you know
but when i meet you or i see you
you seem like such a affable warm and
friendly
it's because they mistake my very
punchy my very at times acerbic wit
and sarcasm as you know i'm this mean
guy i'm i'm
exactly the opposite i'm the the truly
the warmest
friendliest guy but i'm indignant i'm
i'm
angry for exactly the reasons that
you're saying
i'm angry that hundreds of thousands of
students in a world with
limited resources and limited time
instead of studying
many wonderful things and by the way i
don't believe that you could only
you should only be studying in
university you know medicine or law or
business or the natural sciences
you could study the social sciences very
seriously you could study the humanities
very seriously you could study
literature very seriously but there's
always a commitment to a common
discourse
to a commitment to reason irrespective
of whether it's in the humanities the
social sciences or natural sciences
but what i see in the universities it's
a minority but it's certainly a a
powerful minority
they they ruined the lives of thousands
of students
let alone the bank accounts of their
parents
who are spending 70 80 90 000
for somebody to take queering
architecture
and feminist glaciology that angers me
why
and this by the way goes to chapter one
of my of the parasitic mind because
i want to explain exactly why i'm
indignant and and
i argue that there are really two life
ideals that drive who i am
one is truth and the second one is
freedom
and i give examples from many different
areas of my life not just my academic
life
so let's take for example freedom okay
so freedom could be
you know freedom of speech right i'm a
champion of freedom of speech but when i
used to be a competitive soccer player
i played the the playmaker role the
number 10 rule where i just kind of
float around
whenever i had a coach who would put
restrictions on me you're playing today
more
on in left midfield and you have to
track back and cover somebody
suddenly my brain would explode because
you were removing
what i consider to be my greatest asset
which was
to kind of look for spaces to freely
roam around
looking for those opportunities right so
freedom is something that constantly
comes up in my life whether it was when
i was a soccer player
when i'm deciding which topics to pursue
as a scientific project so for example
the reason why i'm a polymath is because
i could never accept
that i'm at a business school therefore
i should only publish
in these types of journals that
suffocates me
the playmaker of academia exactly right
so because of these two driving goals
of freedom and truth i see the world
around me
through very pure lenses so then when i
see
all what i call intellectual terrorists
so the the postmodernists are
right in 911 they flew planes onto
buildings
while the intellectual terrorists they
fly planes of [ __ ]
onto our edifices of reason right that
angers me why
because i come from civil war i come
from chaos
i come from tribalism i come from
identity politics
and now 40 years after leaving this
garbage in lebanon
i now see it taking foot in academia so
yes i wish i didn't have to do it
but to the extent that you see me being
punchy on social media
it comes from indignation not from means
[Music]